♪ ♪
>> Sean:
>> Tean:
>> THIn:
>> THIS:
>> THIS IS HELL.
THIS IS GOING TO DESTROY THE
ABILITY OF GOOD PEOPLE TO COME
FORWARD BECAUSE OF THIS.
TO MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES COME
IF YOU VOTE NO, YOU ARE
LEGITIMIZING THE MOST DESPICABLE
THING I HAVE SEEN IN MY TIME AND
POLITICS.
PERIOD YOU WANT TO SEE IT?
I HOPE YOU NEVER GET IT.
I HOPE YOU ARE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHERE YOU SHOULD
BE.
AND I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL SEE TO THIS CHARADE.
>> Sean:
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM,
SOUTH CAROLINA, ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL MOMENTS OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
BRETT KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION
HEARING LAST YEAR.
WELL, THE LEFT IS STILL NOT DONE
SMEARING JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, THE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN, LISTEN, I'VE
KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME.
THAT WAS YOUR FINEST MOMENT, AND
YOU HAD A LOT OF GOOD MOMENTS
OVER YOUR CAREER.
BUT YOU NOW SEE IT DOESN'T STOP.
AND EVEN DICK DURBIN SAID THIS
IDEA OF IMPEACHING, WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION OF THE TIMES?
IT IS NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY WHEN YOU SPOKE
OF.
>> WHEN YOU THINK YOU HAVE HIT
BOTTOM, IT YOU REALLY HAVEN'T
WHEN IT COMES TO DRUM.
IT IS NOT REALLY NEWS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID A
SLOPPY JOB REPORTING ABOUT TROMP
AND KAVANAUGH BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO BIASED, BUT WHAT IS NEWS TO
ME IS TO COUNITED STATES
SENATORS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
HAVE CALLED FOR KAVANAUGH'S
IMPEACHMENT BASED ON AN
ARTICLE OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"S
ARTICLE OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"B
ARTICLE OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"G
ARTICLE OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"S
ARTICLE OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES".
AND A MEMBER OF THE HOUSES
INTRODUCED IMPEACHMENT
IMPEACHMENT RESOLUTION OF
JUDGE KAVANAUGH BASED ON
ERRONEOUS, SCORELESS NEW YORK
STORY.
SO HERE IS WHAT I WANT YOU TO
KNOW.
ANY IMPEACHMENT TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY IS
DEAD ON ARRIVAL IN THE SENATE.
IN THE IMPEACHMENT OF
SENATOR TRUMP BASED ON THE
MUELLER REPORT IS DEAD ON
ARRIVAL IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
>> Sean: WELL, LET ME ASK YOU
BECAUSE THIS DOVETAILS INTO
THEIR ISSUES.
JOURNALISM IS DEAD.
I EXPECT THIS FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY HAVE NO CREDIBILITY.
AND THE PAPER IS PRINTED ON THIS
POINT.
AND ACTUALLY THIS NEWS, THEY
NEED DONALD DONALD TRUMP MORE
THAN HE NEEDS THEM WHICH IS
INTERESTING, BUT, I GET A LITTLE
ANTSY WAITING FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT,
SENATOR.
I GET A LITTLE ANTSY WHETHER
THEY WILL CONCLUDE WHAT I KNOW
TO BE TRUE.
AND THAT IS, THOSE FOUR FISA
APPLICATION WARRANTS WERE FULL
OF LIES THAT THEY WERE WARNED
ABOUT IT.
RATIONALIZE THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR IT.
THE BULK OF INFORMATION A FAMOUS
MEMO WAS PUT OUT WITH HER NAME
ON IT.
BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT, I WANT
TO HEAR IN NO UNCERTAIN TERMS,
THOSE WARRANTS WERE ILLEGALLY
OBTAINED.
DO YOU THINK I'M LIKELY TO HEAR
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I REALLY DON'T
KNOW.
HORWITZ DID A GOOD JOB TO THE
INVESTIGATION BUT IS NOT A
PROSECUTOR.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SUBPOENA AND INTERVIEW WITNESSES
OUTSIDE OF THE DOJ OR THE FBI.
BUT HERE IS WHAT I DO BELIEVE.
I DO BELIEVE THE WARRANT PROCESS
WAS ABUSED.
NOT ONLY DO I HOPE HE WILL TELL
US THAT IT WAS OFF OF THE RAILS,
I HOPE THE FISA COURT WILL TAKE
THE REPORT SERIOUSLY.
I'M LOOKING FOR THE FISA COURT
TO CLEAN THIS MESS UP.
IF THE COURT DOESN'T TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION, WHY SHOULD WE
TRUST THE COURT IN THE FUTURE?
I'M LOOKING FOR A DORM WHAT
THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE IF THEY
DID IN FACT TAKE FELLOW INTO
THEIR OWN HANDS.
I'M NOT LOOKING TO PROSECUTE
SOMEONE BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE
THEM I WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> Sean: IF YOU ARE WARNED
AHEAD OF TIME THAT THE DOSSIER
IS HILLARY, SHE PAID FOR IT AND
THE GUY THAT OFFERED IT AIDS
TROMP AND YOU ARE ALSO WARNED
IT'S NOT VERIFIED NOT ONCE BUT
AM PROBABLY AT LEAST FOUR AND I
HAVE A SOURCE TELLING ME FIVE OR
SIX TIMES THEY WERE WARNED, THAT
IS PREMEDITATED.
THEN, IF YOU DIDN'T TAKE THE
TIME TO VERIFY, SO NOW WE KNOW
IT'S UNVERIFIABLE.
THE FBI WHEN THEY GOT AROUND TO
VERIFYING IT AFTER THE WARRANTS
WERE ALREADY ISSUED, THEY
DETERMINED IT WAS NOT THE TRUTH.
NONE OF THIS WAS TRUE.
THAT MEANS A PREMEDITATED FRAUD
ON A COURT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SPYING ON AN INDIVIDUAL AND
DENYING THE INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS,
CARTER PAGE, BUT THEN IT IS AN
OPEN DOOR TO ALL THINGS TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
TRANSITION AND PRESIDENCY.
NOW, YOU ARE THE LAWYER.
WHAT I DESCRIBE DOES THAT SOUND
LIKE CRIMES TO YOU?
>> IT SOUNDS HORRIBLE.
IF WE LEGITIMIZE THIS, GOD HELP
US ALL.
IF WE LEGITIMIZE THE FACT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> Sean: I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
A PAIN IN THE NECK, BUT IF I
COMMIT AND GO TO COURT AND MY
LIFE AND I WAS TOLD AHEAD OF
TIME, WHAT YOU ARE TELLING THE
COURT IS A LIE.
IS THAT A CRIME?
>> YES, THAT IS A CRIME TO GET
PAUL'S INFORMATION TO THE COURT.
I'M NOT A PROSECUTOR, HORWITZ IS
NOT A PROSECUTOR BUT WE WILL
LEAVE THAT UP TO DURHAM.
HERE IS WHAT I WANT YOU TO KNOW
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI KNEW THE SOURCE OF THE
DOCUMENT HAD A BIAS AND THEY DID
NOTHING TO ENSURE THE
DOCUMENT WAS RELIABLE IF NOT
RELIABLE TO THIS DAY.
IF THE COURT DOES NOT CLEAR THIS
UP AND TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION,
THEN WHY DO YOU EXPECT PEOPLE IN
THE FUTURE TO BE DETERRED?
IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T GO TO JAIL,
AND IF THE COURT DOESN'T HOLD
THOSE WHO LIED TO THE COURT
ACCOUNTABLE, THEN WE WILL HAVE
MISSED A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
RESTORE THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Sean: I WILL TELL YOU, I
THINK A STEP FURTHER, WE MIGHT
SHRED THE CONSTITUTION.
BECAUSE THAT MEANS --
>> THAT WILL BE A A BAD DAY FOR
AMERICA.
>> Sean: LAST LEGAL QUESTION.
IF YOU'RE SIPPING OF MY EMAILS
AND I DECIDE TO DELETE HALF OF
THEM, AND THEN I BRING IN
COMPUTER EXPERTS TO TELL ME HOW
TO CLEAN MY HARD DRIVE, WIPE IT,
BLEACH IT OUT, AND THEN I HAVE
BEEN MADE OF MINE BUST UP MY
PHONES, MY BLACKBERRIES AND
REMOVE THIS AND CARDS, WOULD YOU
THINK I'M COMMITTING OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THEIR INVESTIGATION AND NUMBER ,
WOULD I NOT BE CHARGED IN
THAT CASE BECAUSE I THINK I
WOULD BUT I'M NOT A LAWYER.
SPEAK WITH THE FIRST THING IF
YOU ARE AT HOME, DON'T TRY THIS
BECAUSE IT WILL NOT WORK OUT FOR
YOU.
THE BOTTOM LINE, IF THERE IS NO
CONSEQUENCES TO TAKE A HAMMER TO
A DEVICE BEING ASKED BY CONGRESS
AND BLEACHING OUT INFORMATION
CONGRESS ONCE, THEN WHAT IS THE
DOWN SIDE OF TO CONGRESS AND
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE WHEN IT
COMES TO CONGRESS.
THIS HAS A BIG DEAL.
I HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN DURHAM,
HORWITZ AND I HAVE A LOT OF
FAITH IN ME.
>> Sean: YOU GUYS WORK FAST.
I WORK 16-17 HOURS A DAY.
WHERE IS THE STUPID REPORT AT
THIS TIME?
I'M GETTING A LITTLE IMPATIENT